Evet
[Müzik]
Merhabalar Öncelikle Çok teşekkür ederim
bu zaman ayırdığınız için uzakta pandemi
döneminde kesinti pes etmemiz gerekiyor
Şu an biraz
önce biraz kariyerinden bahsederek hani
giriş yapmak istiyorum
üniversiteden sonra
yazılım mühendisi olarak bir firmada iş
başı yaptım ve lakin O bir yıl boyu
farkettiğim şuydu artık herkes bir
şeyler yazıyor Ve ve bu veriler
birikiyor bu veri işlendiği zaman bir
anlam kazanıyor ve bunu işleyebilen
insan sayısı ya da bu işgücü sayısı
Türkiye'de çok azdı Ben de o dönem
çalıştım yazılım firmasından ayrıldım
aramadan önce birkaç ay bir kurs aldım
ve Açıkçası bu o anda çalıştığım maaşın
yüzde 30 daha O başka bir firmada Sadece
bu konuda uzmanlaşan bilmek için kendimi
transfer et
çok da ilginçtir bu firmanın özelliği şu
an bizim
veri mühendisliği diye bahsettiğimiz ya
da o kelimenin da hat ortada olmadığı
dönemlerde
böyle bir ekiple çalıştım çünkü projemiz
hastanelerde ya da işte de gittiğinizde
size yazılan ilaçların içerisindeki
suistimallerin tespit edilmesiydi böyle
bir iş için sağlık alanında iki artı iki
bazen 4'tür bazen birdir bazen beştir
doktora denize yağ başım ağrıyor
dediğiniz anda bir kaç milyon tl'lik
faturaları ve denk gelebilirsiniz Çünkü
baş ağrısı çok şey bir kelimedir baş
ağrısı bir kelimedir Onun için hastaneye
gittiğinizde başım ağrıyor demeyin Neyse
tamamını söyleyeyim şimdi bu ekipte iki
doktor iki yazılım beğendi bu severlerin
toparlanması için veren bir oluşturmamız
gerekiyor ver ambarı tarafında versek
Aslında ben çalışıyorum Çok ciddi bir
projeye yaptık
geliştirme şansımız oldu ve teslim ettik
Türkiye'deki projeydi ve çalışma
performansı yüzde yetmiş neredeydi Yani
siz gittiğinizde size bir reçete
verildiğinde bu ve çatı bir suistimal
varsa yüzde yetmiş oranında testte de
biliyorduk
bir gün naçizane olarak bir liste
çıkardık
Türkiye'deki çok büyük bir iş adamının
Fatih'te bir Eczaneden ilaç aldı
gözüküyordu
Bak şimdi biz bunu sigorta şirketine
bildirdik dedi ki bakın işadamı bu
Fatih'teki rastgele bi eczane Bence
bunun üzerine bir düşün Bu tür yüzlerce
küçük örnek var sistem çok DAİŞ yolarak
işledi Birkaç yıl sonra firmayı bir
Alman şirketi geldi satın aldı ve bende
bu dönemde biraz daha Finans ve şey
doğru koymam gerektiğini fark ettim
yavaş yavaş geçiş yapıyorsunuz burada
Evet şimdi
buradaki pes etmedik nokta şu bir
yazılım mühendisi değildim ama kendi
alanımda bağlantılı olsa da herhangi bir
tecrübem olmadığı bir alana doğru geçiş
yaptım o asma sizin için bir fırsat
olabilir çünkü var olan Kalıpları
kırıyorsunuz var olan tecrübenizi
üzerine yeni bir şeyler ekliyorsunuz ve
ortaya çok daha verimli bir şeyler
çıkabiliyor işte burada sunumdaki
örneğindeki gibi
bir anda yemken Aslında rakibinizi
devirecek de verebilecek bir karakter
olabiliyorsunuz ya burada önemli lazım
pes etmemeniz ve doğruyoruz zamanda
doğru hareket edebilmemiz burada şanslı
bir parametre aslında ama önemli olan
senin patates etmeniz
şimdi tfutbol bir hayat felsefesi
dediğimiz bir kavram var şimdi futbol ve
hayat felsefesinde
Ama siz Hayata başladığınızda bir şey
istiyorsanız Sizin bir gol atmanız
yeterli olacaktır
ama yani bir şey çok istiyorsunuz
bağlamda çalışmak istiyorsun size bir
gol yeterli burada Örnek vermek
gerekirse işte Türkiye'den yurtdışına
taşındığında işte çok oturaklı olmayan
bir İngiliz cemle derdimi kıt kanaat
anlattım İngilizcem de iş arama
tecrübesi edilmek zorunda kaldım burada
bitirene biliyorsunuz orada birileri
anons ediyor dört durak sonra trenin
duracağını söylüyorlar Ama siz hala
anlamıyorsunuz devam ediyorsunuz Çünkü
Aksam var oradaki işte tren görevlisinin
farklı bir aksanı var öyle küçük
tecrübelerim de Oldu
oldu bir şeyler öğrenmeye uğraşıyorsunuz
burada ne yapıyorsunuz İngilizce
ingilizcenizi ilerletmek zorundasınız
zaman ayırmak zorundasınız oturuyoruz
biraz ince bakıyorsunuz bu işleme devam
ediyoruz bir anlamda iş aramanız lazım
Çünkü Hayatınız boyunca bir şekilde
ayağınızı Come etmemiz lazım maddi
olarak bak iş arama sürecinde Ben bir iş
zekası uzmanı adam İstanbul'da ve bu Ne
yapıyordum ben kullandığım yani uzman
olduğum alanı iş ararken de kullanmanın
gerektiğini fark ettim oturdum şu mi
İngiltere'deki en bilinen iş ilanı
sitelerinin verilerini her gece otomatik
bir yazılımla topladım bunları aldım Bir
haritanın üzerine yoğunluk olarak
oturttum evimin bulunduğu koordinatlarla
seyahat edebileceğim noktaları
eşleştirdim en Optimum ve bana en uygun
olan iş için birkaç parametre daha
ekledim ve ortaya 5-6 tane ilan çıktı
Ben bu çalışmayı kaydettim bu 5-6 tane
ile ana hafta sonu sevimli düzelterek
başvuruda
bulunduk Pazartesi günü telefonum çaldı
çok
firmanın insan kaynakları
bu uzman olan bir iş arkadaşım Yani iş
arkadaşım oldu Daha sonra beni arıyordu
ya işte seninle görüşmek istiyoruz bir
randevu ayarlayalım şeklinde b bu
dönemde işte İngiltere'nin en alt
kısmında brighton bir şehirde yaşıyorum
brighton trene bindim Londra'ya dedim O
günkü iş görüşmem tüm gülüm aldı
İstanbul'daymış sınız gibi Anadolu
Yakası'nın Avrupa yakasını yaptığım
görüşme çok olumlu geçti Hadi biz
seninle bir sonraki aşamada görüşmek
istiyoruz teknik bulduğumuzda görüşün
lütfen teknik bu durum uzadı görüşmek
için iki gün sonra bir randevu alındı
Ben Bilgisayarım aldım yaptığım
çalışmaları yanıma aldım gittik oturduk
işle ilgili konuşmaya başladık
tecrübelerden bahsetmeye başladık burada
tabi biraz bulunduğumuz yere kültüründe
bilmeniz gerekiyor Mesela iş
görüşmelerinde sevginizin Üzerinde
fotoğraf bulunmaz arkadaşlar sizi yaş ve
ırkçılıktan dolayı ayırt etmeleri için
Siz işinize Çok iyisiniz dır 70 yaşında
olabilirsiniz bu önemli
parametresiz görüşmeye gittim Sevim
vardım konuşmayı yaptık Sonra dedi ki ya
Nasıl oldu ya ve bu iş açtım tek tek
Neler yaptığımı anlattım
dedim ki ben bu işi bulmak için varolan
tecrübemi bu alanda hayatında da
kullanıyorum bayağı bir şaşırdı çok da
ki şey geldi keyifli geldi bana
projelere güvenebileceğiniz düşün Doğan
daha sonra şu anda dostumuzla devam
ediyor Ben ödedik İki gün sonra gel
başla evraklarımı toparladım bilmediğim
bir ülkede Biz az bildiğim bir dille
projelerimiz teslim etmeye başlar
başlayacaktım
o ilk program
biraz İngiltere'nin Kuzey tarafından
manchester'da bir şehirde onların hitab
ile mançester daydı
mançester da dört kişinin oldu bir top
toplantı masasında birkaç tane işte
uzaktan Hindistan'dan
katılan ekipten developerlar var şimdi
bir şeyler konuşuluyor ama
ağır Kuzey aksanı İngiliz Kuzey aksanı
üzerine Hint aksanı ve Benim Türkiye'de
karışık olan türk-ingiliz Aksa'nın
konuşulanların burada sunumda da
belirttiğim gibi ya az önce bu adamların
ne sormuştu sorusunu yeniden tekrar
etmesini rica etmem gerekti ya cümleyi
anlamadım iki kere da tekrar yatmadan
ben nasıl yapacağım bu sefer de
içgüdülerine güvenmeyi tercih ettim
ve son durumda benim her gün her hafta
bir teslimat yapmam gerekiyor çünkü iş
bir paket halinde bir Bu
dünyada ve enerji şirketi aynı zamanda
projeyi edindiğimiz tecrübelerle beraber
isteklerde not olarak teslim etmeyi
başardım çok da şanslıydım ben o projede
üç buçuk ay kadar çalıştım buçuk ay
sonra bana yazdıklarını anlıyorum ama en
başta biraz şanslıydım yani an proje
teslim ettim bundan firmamda Çok memnun
oldu çalıştığım firma
aşkım proje için yönlendirdiler şimdi
istanbuldayken bizim bir ekibimiz vardı
Türkiye'deki Aslında ilk istekası
alanında çalışan
ücretsiz organizasyonlardan bir tanesi
diktik şu an devam edemiyoruz maalesef
işte data ve razı Grup üniversiteleri
gidiyoruz eğitimler veriyoruz iki günlük
grup şoklar yapıyoruz herhangi bir ücret
talep etmiyorduk bu workshoplarda
öğrencilerle konuşuyorduk Yani iş
ararken neye dikkat edeceksiniz oradan
bir kariyer uzmanı sivri nasıl yazılır
işte görüşmeler neler olur ya ondan
sonra biz kamp alıyoruz iki gün boyu
arkadaşlar eğitiyor Çünkü bilgisayar
mavisi öğrencilerin bir sıkıntı var
sadece bilgisayar programı
yazabilecekleri düşünüyordu ama Ayten
içerisinde yüzlerce kol var
ya kendilerine odaklanmaya Bu sadece bir
noktaya odaklanma mamalarını
seçeneklerinin olduğunu gösterdik bu
konuda onlara yardımcı olduk Hala da
görüştüm odandan öğrenciler şu an
Türkiye'deki Telekom şirketinde
bankalarda çalışıyorlar yerinde büyük
market oturup bir çay içiyoruz her zaman
renk geliyoruz şu bu öğrencilerde
görüşürken Şunu fark etmiştim Ben de
sizden rica ediyorum şu Bakın arkadaşlar
çok başarılı öğrenci olabilirsiniz ders
notlarınız çok yüksektir Bursa
olabilirsiniz Ben üniversitedeki en
vasat Öğrencilerden bir tanesini
arkadaşlar beni örnek almayayım ama
burada önemli olan şu derslerinizde
başarılı olun ama sosyal ilişkilerinizde
oturdun bilgisayar mühendisliği son
sınıf Öğrencinin bir yazılım firmasında
35 ayın harcamadan bu bu Anlaşması çok
zor Yani sizi pazar bu şekilde kabul
edecektir
Bu ikisini Beraber oturduğumuz zaman çok
da başarılı olacaksınız ya noktanızı
tutun sosyal ilişkilerinde güvenin yani
topu sadece kitap kurdu olmayan
arkadaşlar
Evet şimdi burada sosyal ilişkiler çok
önemli Çok başarılı bir öğrenci siniz
insanlarla tanışın kaynasın
Her insan sizin için yeni bir değer yeni
bir ders Şimdi burada yine ben dondu da
yaşadığım tecrübelerinden bir tanesini
söyleyeyim
şirketin beni İşte herkes birisi
Avrupa'nın
plan suçlarla ilgili bir projesine
yönlendirdi Bu proje teslim edilecek
ekipte işte farklı ülkelerden insanlar
var mesela
ekip arkadaşlarından bir tanesi Yunan
mıydı gariptir falan görüştüm bir kaçış
arkadaşından bir tanesi Yani oturup
yemek yeriz konuşuruz ya burada din dil
ırk millet Bunlar çok değişik Arkadaşlar
bunlar şey parametreler değil insan
olsun karşınızdaki bir ekiple
Çalışıyorduk biz her cuma akşamı iki
olarak bir araya gelir gider bir şeyler
geldik oha o kendi aramızda kritiği ne
yapardık O hafta
bir numarada bir şey var arkadaşlar
Böyle Hint Restoran tarzında bir yer var
ama damak tatları Bizimkine biraz
benziyor Hindistan'da Pakistan
arasındaki bölgenin yemeklerini
yapıyorlar arada Tayyar fırsatımız
olursa gidin
taraftayız Cuma günü oturduk Bir şeyler
yemeye başladık yanıma bir arkadaş
oturdu bizimle aynı ekipten ama sadece
email birbirimizi tanıdığımız bir
arkadaş
bu görüşmeyi yemeğimizi yerken biraz
öyle kaynaşma ortamı oldu
tanıştık biraz daha sohbet ettik işte
Emlak fiyatlarını bilmem neydi böyle
genel güncel konular
sonra ben bu görüşmeden iki yıl sonra
var olan şirketinden ayrılmam
gerektiğine Londra'da kendi işim yapmam
gerektiğini Artık karar verdim artık
Kendi Ayakları üzerinde durup ya da
girişimci olmam gerekiyordu
bu sefer ben şey yaptım
bu durumda görüştüm dedi ki ben
bırakacağım biraz ara vereceğim ondan
sonra kendi işimi yapacağım Öyle
bildiğiniz bir Yeni yıla işsiz ve
umutlarla giriş yap
o dönemde yeniden tekrar işte iş Olası
iş şeyleri kovalıyorum işte projeler
falan falan Sonra bir insan kaynakları
uzmanı Head Hunter diğerini daha çok
Belki de daha anlamlı olacaktır aradı
beni ya bir projemiz var bir Finans
tarafında yapar mısın yaparım bir
görüşelim falan da görüştük çok da
olumlu geçti teknikle görüşme yapılması
gerektiği söylendi ektik görüşmeyi
yaptığımızda
fark ettim ki ama aslında teknik
görüşmeyi telefonda yaptığım kişi benim
ta yoksa beraber yemek yediğim kişiydi
yani insanlarla ilişkilerinizi iyi Tutun
bir yerlerde çalışıyor olabilirsiniz
bizsiz bazen iş Arkadaşlarınıza
ailenizden Daha çok göreceksiniz Onun
için iş arkadaşlarınızla Bence kavga
etmenin sürtüşme nin lüzumsuz şeylere
girmenin gereği yok Çünkü ailenizden
daha çok gördüğünüz insanlar
olabiliyorlar Bu Alman derslerden bir
tanesi olalım olmalıdır Yani bu arkadaş
benim hayatıma bir dokunuş yaptı ben
ondan sonra genelde finanse gibi çok
ciddi projeler aldım şu an Londra
Borsası işlerini yapıyorum
Ha
bir de genel olarak bizim öğrencilerle
konuşurken
farkettiğiniz şey Çünkü arkadaşlar
özgüveniniz olsun özgüvensiz hiçbir iş
olmaz korkak tırsak olmayın ama lütfen
bunu EGO ile karıştırmayın bilmediğiniz
bir konu hakkında yorum yaparken iki kez
düşünün karşınızdaki kişi daha çok
biliyor olabilir ya bu işi bir şeye
dönüştürmeyin bu çok önemli yani bu
anlamda çok başarılı olursunuz
Evet
şimdi
A bu da yine seviyor örnek olacaktır
Hadi olmadığınız kişilerin işlerini
hayatınızda dokunması
bu şöyle bir örnek vereyim size
bir sigorta şirketinin projesine
çalışıyorum mesai saatlerim çok şey
akşam 9'lara falan bulabiliyor
akşam çalışıyorum Her akşam o bizim
Ofisi temizleme iki kişi geliyor Bir
erkek bir bayan ya da var benim masamın
etrafını temizler ve bana dokunmazlar
Çalışıyorum hala Sonra işte bir
merhabalaşma ya başladık konuşmaya
başladı çünkü etrafınızdaki insanlarla
dostane oğlum yani Eninde sonunda
Hepimiz bir şekilde toprak olacağız
sohbet etmeye başladık
anne vb oğul beraber çalışıyorlar
hemen komşumuz buradan Bulgaristan'dan
Onlar da benim gibi göçmem
Onlar şu an benim dondurmadaki
aylarından bir tanesi
mı görüşüyoruz Hatta onların evinde
kalıyorum gittiğin zaman
yani garip bir şey var burada o çocuk
temizlikçi Çünkü İngilizce bilmiyordu
ama Bulgaristan'da satılan on plan
9'unun yapımcısı dış bu
onun için
ummadığın kişiler hayatımda dokunabilir
mesela iskoçyada yine böyle çok sevdiğim
bir abim var burada önemli olan dediğim
gibi din dil Irk ne oldu önemli kişinin
insan olması gittiğim zaman orada bir
sıcak kahvem var hoş karşılanabilir
yorum Bunlar çok önemli ilişkilerin
sıcak su Arkadaşlar şimdi hiçbir şekilde
pes etmemiz gerekiyor
Bu önemli bir şey
Az önceki konutlarda anlattılar pes
etmediler bazen de oyunu değiştirmeleri
gerekti bu işte buradayım
Ama siz Madem biliyorsunuz bu oyunu
kaybedeceksiniz bir terslik var oyunu
değiştirme arkadaşlar kendinizi değil
de
bundan sonrası için önerebileceğim Asla
Pes etmeyin ha
O
çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]